[Music]
foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday April 19th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
ukrainians looking for a new home
following Russia's invasion of their
country are being recruited to move to
Tulsa Oklahoma the city wants to become
a regional Tech Hub and displaced
ukrainians offer the engineering skills
many businesses need join me to discuss
how the program works and what it's like
for new arrivals is Alicia Caldwell who
covers immigration for the Wall Street
Journal so Alicia tell us a bit about
how this program works and who it's
trying to attract to Tulsa there's this
non-profit group in Tulsa Oklahoma
called the in Tulsa Visa Network it's an
offshoot of another recruitment group
and they're trying to recruit Ukrainian
would-be Parolees basically people who
are allowed to move to the U.S under the
uniting for Ukraine program they're
allowed to come here for two years as
soon as they get off the plane they're
eligible to work and specifically in
Tulsa is looking for those ukrainians
who want to move to Tulsa and have high
tech skills specifically stem degrees
people working in that field already
ready to hit the ground running so far
how many people have they attracted to
Tulsa they've got about 15 approved for
their side of the program and then those
folks of course are in various stages of
process with the US government because
you also have to be approved by the US
government and you get a sponsor and
you're allowed to come to the U.S in
this case one of the organizers of in
Tulsa is acting as the sponsor and in
Tulsa the Visa Network acts as the
broader sponsor in the sense of helps
you get housing picks you up at the
airport arranges four-year travel and
once you get here or in Sometimes some
cases before you arrive they'll start
connecting you with would-be employers
you've got an interview of course
there's no guaranteed any one employer
is going to pick you but you start
interviewing and hopefully you get
placed with job and you go forward
you've spoken to some of these people
what has their experience been like
moving to Tulsa taking up this
opportunity it's been interesting I
spoke with a man named Andre skoriakov
he and his family two daughters and his
wife moved in December and when they
were looking at this program initially
online when they were living in France
last year
Andre said he thought it might be a scam
and then he spoke to one of the
organizers who himself emigrated from
Ukraine as a child and they spoke and he
felt far more comfortable obviously and
went down that process he's now working
remotely in Tulsa from his new
three-bedroom house just outside
downtown Tulsa he says it's a big change
for the family they're used to living in
an urban center they're from Kiev and
they were in you know a big apartment
building and now they've got the single
family home in the Suburban area and
it's a change but it's a nice change for
them obviously they're no longer
concerned about the war coming to their
front door though their oldest son
remains in Ukraine he gets a military
service as well as finishing his college
degree and hopes at some stage to become
a commercial pilot and Andre has said
he'd like to help him help his son move
to the United States and pursue that
career path as he himself gets settled
here in the U.S are there any additional
limitations that these programs place on
them not especially with uniting for
Ukraine things are actually a lot easier
for these particular immigrants right
they are
approved to come to the United States
and as soon as they stepped foot on U.S
soil you know you're flying to JFK you
go through immigration you're legally
eligible to work which is a huge
difference compared to Asylum Seekers
for instance who come across the
Southwest border who are basically on
their own once they're released from U.S
government custody if they're released
they have to navigate a system on their
own
ukrainians and other people who are
allowed to come in under these parole
programs and it's expanding to four
other Latin American countries Cuba
Haiti Venezuela and Nicaragua they are
in a much better position for the
ukrainians for instance they're eligible
for some social welfare benefits that
are typically reserved for refugees
while these folks are not legally
defined as refugees they're treated in
much the same way and with the
sponsorship program generally the
sponsor is on the hook if you will to
help you find a house help you get
settled possibly find language classes
get some educational training if your
career doesn't necessarily translate
directly or if your degrees don't
translate directly with uniting for
Ukraine matching up with in Tulsa the
goal is to skip some of those steps if
you will right because it's already
built in by by in Tulsa you mentioned
they're allowed to come here for a
couple of years can you tell us more
about that could these ukrainians stay
in the country longer if they wanted to
right now their parole is eligible for
two years and it's the same for those
other four countries and in Tulsa
Network we'll try to help where it can
for those who decide they want to stay
is there an Avenue by which they can
change their status and become either
permanent residents or obtain a visa to
stay beyond that two years and frankly
we don't know what will happen when
these paroles start to expire obviously
the war in Ukraine
continues and its fate is still yet to
be determined and the US government's
determination on what to do with those
parole dates is still up in the air
talk a little bit about the tech scene
in Tulsa what's it like and how are they
trying to develop it it's growing and
they're struggling I'm told to find
workers so the in Tulsa program the the
non-profit that's then spawned the Visa
Network started out recruiting Tech
workers to Tulsa just U.S residents and
people working in the U.S come to Tulsa
we've got all these jobs help us fill
them
then they expanded to the Visa Network
once the uniting for Ukraine program was
developed they saw a dual purpose there
right you can help people escape this
war and fill jobs so basically the goal
writ large in in this burgeoning
community is to make Tulsa something of
attack Hub a Silicon Valley of the
Heartland is the is the program is this
strategy something other cities are also
trying to emulate not that I've seen so
far right now it's not a city sponsored
program but the mayor of Tulsa mayor
Bynum is super aggressive and welcoming
immigrants he's a republican in a very
red State who said you know what this is
an approach I want to take our
population has grown because of
immigration because of foreign-born
people moving into Tulsa it's gone from
nine percent to about 11 percent of the
population over the last couple of years
he sees an economic driver there all
right that's our reporter Alisa Caldwell
thanks for joining us
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign